though you can choose your best side or
adjust lighting taking selfies isn't
always about being in control for
thousands of children across the UK they
can result in sexual abuse over the
course of the conversation she piled on
a lot of compliments to me about how
pretty I was and you know you beautiful
and you could be a model just like me
Rhiannon is now in her 30s but when she
was 13 she was sexually abused by
someone she met online a senator topless
picture and almost immediately her
demeanor changed and it went from
[Music]
complimenting me and asking nice
questions to essentially blackmail the
next morning a man came to her house she
didn't know at the time but this was the
same person she'd been speaking to
online he sexually assaulted me in my
bedroom and he took more photos of what
was happening the internet watch
foundation calls this the dark side of
the selfie it took action over more than
a hundred and twenty thousand images of
child abuse found online around 30
percent of those were self generated of
those more than three-quarters featured
11 to 13 year olds and the majority were
girls sexual images of a child are a
visual record of the abuse they faced
these can be videos or photos young
people take on their phones and share
through apps like snapchat and Instagram
there at a time when they're easily
coerced and manipulated and tricked into
sharing images and doing things online
and by the time we see those videos and
images they've made their way onto
pedophilic child sexual abuse websites
the sheer scale of the problem means
police can't deal with it alone it's
prompted this campaign by the IWF and
the Marie Collins foundation all
Internet users they say need to
understand that you're breaking the law
if you view sexual images of children
regardless of who's taken or uploaded
them and so the IWF is helping anyone
who comes across such content to report
it anonymously using this quick and
simple form on its web
it could help Internet companies remove
images faster
Sadia Chaudhary Sky News